le crabe est une bête féroce capable de
pinces et fort il faut porter des gants
pour le manipuler
mais cette année c'est plutôt un
pincement au coeur que craignent
notamment lui à rentrer avec 5000 flyers
d'habitude d'offre de 31 40 45 à travers
chaque trahi
j'ai changé à cette bande des quatre
depuis le début de la saison de la pêche
au crabe
les affaires tournent au ralenti pour
cause la fermeture d'une grande zone
pour protéger les baleines noires et
d'ici jeudi
trois nouvelles zones seront fermées
temporairement comme celle d'auxerre en
date du voyage
pinault qui est en ce moment donné
forçant les crédits à se concentrer au
même endroit cette année on écope de six
jours - un collègue jean jaurès à la
ressource selon les pêcheurs est presque
déjà toutes exploitées pour yves
celtitude jeunes d'abord fait plutôt
leur payer pareil le ministre des pêches
et des océans agi ainsi pour éviter
l'hécatombe de l'été dernier 18 des 450
baleine noire restantes sont mortes dans
les eaux canadiennes et américaines des
nécropsies ont prouvé que les engins de
pêche aux crabes ont causé la mort de
certaines d'entre elles mais alain et
incrédule je me dis que parce que tu des
bateaux qui pêchent a pas vu aucune
balle en or si les pêcheurs sont
durement touchés le travailleur du sinn
comme dany le sont tout autant
dix ans on travaille en fait tu es
petite soeur la mode sait plus quoi
faire
bilan après aval puis d'amendé 9h 16h
dans cette usine sont considérablement
coupé
frustré on est révolté les coeurs dans
le maquis dans vive la pression des
américains pour protéger la belle et
noir est bien réel affirme ottawa en
pleine négociation de l'alena avec les
états unis aux questions de déplaire aux
voisins du sud et le ministre des pêches
et des océans dominic leblanc l'a répété
souvent à ceux qui seraient tentés de
désobéir au règlement les amendes
pourraient être salée ici et les à céret
radio-canada cas raquette